mal j'étais en train de faire des stades
tout à l'heure moi
aussi les partiels qui vont
arriver audreé Gautier 19 ans vit sur le
campus HC Paris à joui en Josas en
septembre 2023 cette étudiante a intégré
le programme grande école pour devenir
consultante en conseil financier depuis
la rentrée elle participe aux actions de
la FM Téléton comme bénévole la jeune
femme consacre environ 4h hebdomadaires
à l'antenne Eveline est à Guill encour
ses missions fournir le matériel pour
les activité de weekend de mobilisation
et accompagner les organisateurs dans la
pédagogie auprès du grand public même si
les personnes ne sont absolument pas
réticente à donner et faire un don pour
la recherche médicale ils ont encore du
mal à voir forcément parfois ce à quoi
va servir leur don et donc c'est vrai
que l'engagement auprès du Téléton
c'était notamment une volonté pour moi
de partager mon expérience et aussi
montrer que finalement le handicap ça
n'arrête pas la vie et que c'est pas
parce qu'on est handicapé qu'on peut pas
faire des belles études et qu'on peut
pas avoir une belle vie et avoir plein
d'activités extras scolaires qui sont
absolument passionnantes audrey est
atteinte d'une miasténie autoimmune
depuis sa naissance résultant d'un
dysfonctionnement du système immunitaire
cette pathologie entraîne une hyper
fatigabilité des muscles il lui est
impossible de faire un sport intensif ou
de marcher trop longtemps mais grâce aux
avancés de la recherche Audrey peut
aujourd'hui être autonome et
indépendante le but du traitement est
vraiment en fait d'effacer les
conséquences de la maladie et pas encore
vraiment d'éradiquer les causes donc ça
veut dire que je vivrai toute ma vie
avec avec la
maladie après c'est vrai que le
traitement m'a beaucoup stabilisé m'a
beaucoup aidé c'est vrai que moi ça se
voit pas et en plus j'ai tendance à en
faire beaucoup plus que tout le monde
parce que je veux pas qu'on voit que je
suis handicapé je sais qu'il y a une
anecdote qui me fait encore beaucoup
rire aujourd'hui en 6e j'ai eu une
professeur de sport qui m'a mis un mot
dans le carnet parce que j'avais oublié
mes affaires de sport alors que je suis
dispensée à l'année depuis que je suis
né donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ça ça
me fait encore beaucoup rire mais en
fait pour moi c'est vraiment une preuve
du fait que aujourd'hui encore un
handicapé qui est pas en ute il ça se
comprend pas comme un handicapé une vie
remplie de projets dans quelques
semaines Audrey s'envolera vers
Stockholm en Suède pour un échange
académique de 5 mois passionnée de tir à
l'arc elle souhaiterait aussi ouvrir un
club avec ses amis avant tout cela la
jeune femme profitera des 30 heur de
Téléton pour mettre en lumière les 23000
personnes atteintes de miasteni en
France